[Music]
welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you mitzy so great to be here
today
at the banana banana moore's banana
ramamore's banana morris morse
this is great this is amazing mitzi i
got into
this business show business 25 years ago
to become a movie star now
i'm standing in front of a banner with a
banana telling jokes
into a computer in my house what
happened
i have to set up this whole thing in my
garage
that's all i have i you know why i'm in
my garage because my wife and kids
have taken over my house with the
lockdown they're out there right now in
the house they're zooming they're
booming they're gooming
everything i have they took over i
i'll tell you i'll tell you this is the
other thing
my agents my managers said listen
there's no touring this year
this is last year once the pandemic
started there's no touring under the
pandemic
but it's a good time for you to build up
your social media you got to start
posting some videos
so i did i started posting videos and i
don't know why but every time i post a
video
i lose 120 followers what is that
why are they leaving where are they
going
just give the video a thumbs down but
don't leave
where are you going and the comments
on social media forget it people drive
me nuts
oh listen first of all
last year i decided to lose
10 pounds by running and eating right
that's what i decided
and then i thought you know what i'm
gonna do i'm going
to inspire my fans to also
exercise lose weight let's do it
together
so i said i'm going to start posting
pictures of my weight loss
as i go i when i stood on my little
electric scale
i stood there i took pictures every day
i would post pictures
of my weight loss as i went along
started reading the comments
right away comment number one dude your
toes are
ugly what the i'm trying to inspire you
to lose weight
why are you worried about my toes
every comment was about my ugly toes i
stopped running
yeah what are you gonna do
i can't wait to get back on the road
thank you for having me
at the banana moors comedy club stay
safe
and namaste laugh at your screen
thanks for coming to bananamores
i can't even contain my excitement for
this next comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of
[Applause]
hey clapping how are you it's nothing
just being here um introductions
i guess uh i'm tina
and i'm disabled
and don't worry you're going to be okay
i am well i'm kind of disabled right
no not really though you know who
i'm kind of half and half like i'm not
totally committed to the lifestyle
of it i'm kind of like
like the the bisexuality of ability
right
so i'm a bit of an enigma right like
people will see me and they don't know
what's
happening you know they don't know what
to say
but that doesn't stop them
so i i get a lot of weird things said to
me
like um you don't look like you should
be
disabled right like like it's a hogwarts
house
it would never let me into hogwarts by
the way i'd be
a huge liability you know like
they've got stairs that move like
like the one time that kind of voice
activated
siri technology that i just do
not job with you know like
i don't i know that one miscommunication
and it would end up setting fire
to someone's esophagus
why can't you compliment me like a
normal person
you've got so many options
i will never talk one time back in like
high school
i was in art class painting like a color
wheel
and a girl leaned over to me and she
said tina
it's so cool you're disabled
but you're actually good at stuff
like what do you say to that
that is a common misconception buggy
i mean it's not that i'm actually good
at
all this stuff right i'm just
particularly bad
at being disabled
but the thing is that like i used to
think that i would grow
out of this you know like
in my defense though for the molecular
amount of media representation that we
have today there was even
less of it back in the early 2000s
you know like back when i was a kid
we had nothing on tv like me
we had like drake in a wheelchair
that was it
i love making that reference oh god it
really divides the room
you guys you got it right
not so much over here
he doesn't even know where he is
no but i'll all explain so back when i
was a kid
there was a channel on tv of course
t-neck right which was nickelodeon
but for eight-year-olds with their
parents in the other room
right and there was kissing and
people died and it was powerful
and on that channel there was a show
called
grassy and onto grassy there was a kid
in a wheelchair played by drake
the rap you're like i'm not making this
okay so naturally i
thought that i would just grow up to be
like a rap mogul
[Applause]
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has the banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya ah
yes this next performer
she really lights up the banana more
stage
hey everyone so good to be here um i
can't believe i'm doing stand-up comedy
again because i was quarantined with my
family
for six months don't recommend that
oh man i just i'm glad that 2020 is
finally over okay that was a crazy year
we had the pandemic we had protests
taylor swift released two albums it was
nuts nobody saw that coming
but my favorite thing that happened in
2020 was uh there was this giant
wildfire that was started by a gender
reveal party
i don't know if you guys remember the
story and i read all the articles about
it and i got
so mad because i
still don't know what gender the baby is
yeah i'm like wasn't that the whole
point of the party you're like i don't
care how many acres of land you burn
down
is it a boy or is it a girl let me know
yeah turns out the gender was fire so
that's also what this gender is i did
get a haircut recently finally
um that was the toughest part about the
pandemic for me was i couldn't get a
haircut for months
and my hair was getting so long that i
didn't even look gay anymore yeah i was
like showing up to the zoo meetings and
people are like
who's that straight girl i'm like oh
this is a problem
there's a reason my hair looks like this
it's for women
so yeah i actually had to spend uh my
second
birthday on zoom this year uh have you
guys been to a zoom party they're
terrible okay
like have you guys had 10 people saying
happy birthday to you
not at the same time yeah you can hear
individually how bad of a singer
everyone is but the worst part is you
can't really
leave the zoom there's no good excuse
like back when we went to real life
parties
you could just be like hey man great
party uh where's the bathroom
and then you just go home right but on
zoom you can't be like
hey um i gotta go to another room in my
house yeah i'd rather stare at my wall
than be here with you so
i'm just gonna pretend my wi-fi stopped
working next time i think that's the
only way to get out of it
i will say at this point uh it's been a
year that we've been inside
if your ex has not reached out to you
you've never been in love
okay like we've all talked to our exes
at this point
just to check up on them you know i just
want to make sure that i'm doing
better than you yeah i don't want you be
doing bad just like worse than me
all right uh thank you guys so much i've
been irene too